so traders in Africa immediately noticed
the problem with these men so what did
they do they gave them a bunch of
oranges a week later the men that were
still living healed miraculously of
course de Gama never acknowledged that
these heathens would have some sort of
cure for them he instead had his men
pray with their mouths full of their own
urine which I'm sure many of you did
this morning if you're anything like me
so of the hundred and sixty sailors that
set out on this voyage one hundred would
die of scurvy meanwhile in the West
jacques-cartier 16th century French
explorer was leading an expedition to
the eastern Canadian areas when a ship
got stuck in a frozen Inlet soon the
food started rotting things got really
bad really quickly Cartier wrote the
unknown sickness began to spread itself
amongst us after the strangest SOT that
ever was heard or seen in so much as
some did lose all their strength and
could not stand on their feet then did
their legs swell their sinews shrink as
black as any coal with such infection
did the sickness spread itself into our
three ships that about the middle of
February of a hundred and ten persons
that were there were not ten whole so it
wasn't the cold air that was killing off
Cartier's men of course it was their
really crappy rotten diet around the
sixteenth century almost all sailors
didn't matter if you were from Britain
or Portugal or France or whatever they
were basically eating the same thing and
this was their weekly ration four pounds
of salted beef seven pounds of biscuits
two pounds of salted pork a half pound
of salted fish a chunk of butter a chunk
of cheese and check this out one gallon
of beer every day it's a 12 pack of beer
every day and with that beer they ate
their salted meat and they included that
with exactly zero for
and vegetables so it was a diet that was
just built for scurvy and there's a
Michael showed I mean you saw those last
five food groups that have zero vitamin
C that's what they were eating so
meanwhile in South Pacific Polynesian
sailors were spending weeks and weeks at
sea and going tremendous distances but
there were no written instances of
scurvy why is that because their diet
consisted of fruits vegetables tubers
fish and instead of beer what did they
have to drink coconut water so just a
couple of coconuts is plenty of vitamin
C to keep scurvy at bay and to heal you
if you have problems but cardiod didn't
know about that back in the in the
doldrums of Canada here he was desperate
to find a cure for his men so he talked
to the Iroquois Indians who told him to
use the branches of the annada tree and
to boil them so Cartier did that he
boiled them gave the steed all of his
men who would have guessed a week later
the men who were still alive were
totally healed so kardi of course never
acknowledged that either he just this is
if these guys were pretty stubborn by
the mid 1700s there were several dozen
cures for scurvy that had been
documented over the past 3,000 years but
British American and Portuguese doctors
either never got wind of them which
seems improbable or more likely they
refused to prescribe them because they
were considered barbaric unscientific or
even worse French
[Music]